this is Kenya's bony Forest it has a
rich Coastal ecosystem providing
Sanctuary for rare Wild Life plants and
beds thousands of people depend on it
for their
livelihood but they face danger
government forces are fighting the armed
group Al chabab deep within the forest
that borders
Somalia in recent years the fighters
have carried out a series of attacks on
civilians and security
Personnel Joseph jog is a farmer and
says the security situation is farther
Complicated by historical tensions over
land between Ranch owners and some
people from other parts of Kenya who
settled in lamu decades
ago I feel horrible being called a
squatter in my own country I hope I can
get proper documents and a solution
between us the government and the
Rangers
we just want to live in peace I'm
talking to the ranch owners government
officials say they're trying to deal
with the issue we need to
stop other people from coming in we have
to draw a line so that we address and
resolve those who are now here and we
see what to do but if people still keep
moving in and moving in into people's
ranches then this problem will not be
solvable every day when the sun sets on
Bonnie Jog and other squarters make
their way to their school the school was
attacked a few months ago by armed men
and soldiers have pitched Camp here
nearly 300 people including children
come to spend their night in this school
right now they are registering to make
sure that everyone has come uh safely uh
what happens is that they go to their
farms in the morning and then they come
to sleep here they sleep in uh
classrooms here many people who lived in
the ranches have fled to other
areas some like jog say they have
nowhere else to call home Katherine soy
Al jazer jurri Village lamu County